[Music]
principal Botwin there's so many guys in
the school they're way better looking at
me I'm the only one who hasn't gotten a
girl are you saving yourself for
marriage no oh
are you well asexual because I have a
pamphlet for that this is America and in
American high school if you're not hot
you need something else to get popular
you're not gonna get girls unless you're
the jock the drug dealer I just have
that one thing that golden ticket I know
I get quarters [ __ ] me and my pajamas
food I told you that's been my childhood
best friend
we stole comics looks like a different
species than me I don't know if it's
gonna work out between the two of us
anyway honey you're good-looking too
he's okay he's like five six tops
they're new here right well my friend
Christian Peterson is having an ABC
party on Thursday Zach and I are gonna
be working on our comic book together
this weekend oh and you can bring your
friend too if you want then we have to
go you're hot now with great looks comes
great responsibility
[Music]
first things first you're getting a
makeover wearing the jeggings I thought
you of course I would man
jesus [ __ ] christ has everybody
humping each other
it's called grimy and it's literally the
best invention ever one time I got so
drunk I said the dick-pic to my son oh
he's blocked me
[Music]
sweet name of barn oh yeah you guys know
how to have fun
yeah you left the party am i right dude
yeah
I'm so glad I got into education
you should totally hang out again
[Music]